This lecture is about natural language
content analysis.
As you see from this picture, this is
really the first step to process any
text data, text data in natural
languages.
So computers have to understand natural
language to some extent in order to
make use of the data.
So that's the topic
of this lecture.
We're going to cover three things.
First, what is natural language
processing?
Which is the main technique for
processing natural language to obtain
understanding?
The second is the state of the art in
NLP, which stands for natural language
processing.
Finally, we're going to cover the
relation between natural language
processing and text retrieval.
First what is NLP?
Well the best way to explain it is to think
about if you see a text in a foreign
language that you can understand.
Now what do you have to do in order to
understand that text?
This is basically what computers are
facing, right?
So looking at the simple sentence like
a dog is chasing a boy on the
playground.
We don't have any problem with
understanding this sentence.
But imagine what the computer would
have to do in order to understand it,
or in general it would have to do the
following.
First we have to know dogs are a noun
chasing is a verb etc.
So this is called lexical analysis or
part of speech tagging.
And we need to figure out the syntactic
categories of those words.
So that's the first step.
After that, we're going to figure out
the structure of the sentence.
So for example, here it shows that A
and a dog would go together
to form a noun phrase.
And we won't have dog and is to go
first, and there are some structures
that are not just right.
But this structure shows what we
might get if we look at the sentence
and try to interpret the sentence.
Some words would go together 1st and
then they will go together with other
words.
So here we show we have noun phrases as
intermediate components and then verbal
phrases.
Finally we have a sentence.
And to get this structure we need to
do something called a syntactic
analysis or parsing, and we may have a
parser.
A computer program that would
automatically create this structure.
Now at this point you would know the
structure of this sentence, but still
you don't know the meaning of the
sentence, so we have to go further to
semantic analysis.
In our mind, we usually can map such a
sentence to what we already know in our
knowledge base.
And for example, you might imagine a
dog that looks like that there's a boy
and there's some activity here.
But for a computer would have to use
symbols to denote that, right?
So we would use a symbol D1 that denote
a dog and B1 to denote a boy and then
P1 to denote the playground,
playground.
Now there is also chasing activity
that's happening here, so we have a
relation chasing here that connects all
these symbols.
So this is how computer would obtain
some understanding of this sentence.
Now from this representation we could
also further infer some other things,
and we might indeed naturally think of
something else when we read the text,
and this is called inference.
So for example, if you believe that if
someone is being chased and this person
might be scared with this rule, you can
see computers could also infer that
this boy may be scared.
So this is some extra knowledge that
you would infer based on understanding
of the text.
You can even go further to understand
why the person said this sentence, so
this has reduced the use of language.
This is called.
Pragmatic analysis.
In order to understand the speech actor
of a sentence.
Like we say something to basically
achieve some goal.
There's some purpose there, and this
has to do with the use of language.
In this case, the person who said this
sentence might be reminding another
person to bring back the dog.
That could be one possible intent to
reach this level of understanding would
require all these steps.
And a Computer would have to go through
all these steps in order to
completely understand this sentence.
Yet we humans have no trouble with
understanding that, we instantly will get
everything.
And there is a reason for that.
That's because we have a large
knowledge base in our brain and we can
use common sense knowledge to help
interpret the sentence.
Computers unfortunately, are hard to
obtain such understanding.
They don't have such a knowledge base,
they are still incapable of doing
reasoning under uncertainties.
So that makes natural language
processing difficult for computers.
But the fundamental reason why a
natural language processing is
difficult for computers is simply because
natural language has not been designed
for computers.
They natural languages are designed for
us to communicate.
There are other languages designed for
computers.
For example program languages.
Those are harder for us, so natural
languages is designed to make our
communication efficient.
As a result, we omit a lot of common
sense knowledge because we assume
everyone knows about that.
We also keep a lot of ambiguities
because we assume the receiver or the
hearer could know how to disambiguate
ambiguous word based on the knowledge
or the context.
There's no need to invent the different
words for different meanings.
We could overload the same word with
different meanings without the problem.
Because of these reasons, this makes
every step in natural language
processing difficult.
For computers, ambiguity is the main
difficulty.
And common sense reasoning is often
required.
That's also hard.
So let me give you some examples of
challenges here.
Consider the word level ambiguity.
The same word can have different
syntactic categories.
For example, design can be a noun or a
verb.
The word root may have multiple
meanings, so square root in math sense,
or the root of a plant.
You might be able to think of other
meanings.
There are also syntactical ambiguities, for
example.
The main topic of this lecture, natural
language processing can actually be
interpreted in two ways in terms of the
structure.
Think for a moment to see if you can
figure that out.
We usually think of this as processing
of natural language.
But you could also think of this as you
say, language processes is natural.
Alright, so this is an
example of syntactic ambiguity where we
have different structures that can be
applied to the same sequence of words.
Another common example of an ambiguous
sentence is the following.
A man saw a boy with a telescope.
Now in this case, the question is who
had the telescope?
Right, this is called a prepositional
phrase attachment.
Ambiguity, or PP attachment ambiguity.
Now we generally don't have a problem
with these ambiguities.
Because
we have a lot of background and
knowledge to help us disambiguate the
ambiguity.
Another example of difficulties is
anaphora resolution, so think about the
sentence like John
persuaded Bill to buy a TV for
himself.
The question here is does himself refer
to John or Bill?
So again, this is something that you
have to use some background or the
context to figure out.
Finally, presupposition is another
problem.
Consider the sentence.
He has quit smoking.
This obviously implies that he smoked
before.
So imagine a computer wants to
understand all these subtle differences
and meanings.
It would have to use a lot of knowledge
to figure that out.
It also would have to maintain a large
knowledge knowledge base of all the
meanings of words and how they are
connected to our common sense knowledge
of the world.
So This is why it's very difficult.
So as a result, we are still not
perfect, in fact, far from perfect in
understanding natural language using
computers.
So this slide sort of gives simplified
view of state of the art technologies.
We can do part of speech tagging pretty
well, so I showed 97% accuracy here.
Now this number is obviously based on a
certain data set, so don't take this
literally.
It just shows that we can do it pretty
well, but it's still not perfect.
In terms of parsing, we can do partial
parsing pretty well.
That means we can get noun phrase
structures or verbal phrases structures,
or some segment of the sentence
understood correctly in terms of the
structure.
An in some evaluation results we have
seen above 90% accuracy in terms of
partial parsing of sentences.
Again, I have to say these numbers are
relative to the data set in some other
data sets.
The numbers might be lower.
Most of the existing work has been
evaluated using news data set and so a
lot of these numbers are more or less
biased toward news data.
Think about the social media data, the
accuracy likely is lower.
In terms of semantic analysis.
We are far from being able to do a
complete understanding of a sentence.
But we have some techniques that would
allow us to do partial understanding of
the sentence.
So I could mention some of them.
For example, we have techniques that
can allow us to extract the entities
and relations mentioned in text
articles.
For example, recognizing the mentions
of people, locations, organisations,
etc in text.
So this is called entity extraction.
We may be able to recognize the
relations, for example this person
visited that place or this person met
that person, or this company acquired
another company.
Such relations can be extracted by
using the current natural language
processing techniques.
They're not perfect, but they can do
well for some entities.
Some entities are harder than
others. We can also do word sense
disambiguation to some extent.
We can figure out whether this word in
this sentence would have certain
meaning in another context.
The computer could figure out it has a
different meaning.
Again, it's not perfect, but you can do
something in that direction.
We can also do sentiment analysis,
meaning to figure out the weather
sentence is positive or negative.
This is especially useful for review
analysis, for example.
So these are examples of semantic
analysis and they help us to obtain
partial understanding of the sentences.
It's not giving us a complete
understanding as I showed it before for
this sentence, but it would still help
us gain understanding of the content,
and these can be useful.
In terms of inference, we are not there
yet, partly because of the general
difficulty of inference and
uncertainties.
This is a general challenging in
artificial intelligence.
That's partly also because we don't
have complete semantic representation
for natural language text, so this is
hard yet in some domains, perhaps in
limited domains, when you have a lot of
restrictions on the word uses, you
maybe do may be able to perform
inference.
To some extent, but in general we
cannot really do that.
reliably. Speech Act analysis is also
far from being done, and we can only do
that analysis for various special
cases.
So this roughly gives you some idea
about the state of the art.
And then we also talk a little bit
about what we can't do.
And so we can't even do one hundred
percent part of speech tagging.
Now this looks like a simple task, but
think about the example here.
The two users of off may have different
syntactic categories.
If you try to make a fine grained
distinguishing, it's not that easy to
figure out such differences.
It's also hard to do general,
complete parsing, and again this same
sentence that you saw before is example.
This ambiguity
can be very hard to disambiguate,
and you can imagine example where you
have to use a lot of knowledge in the
context of the sentence or from the
background in order to figure out who
actually had the telescope.
So although the sentence looks very
simple, it actually is pretty hard, and
in cases when the sentence is very
long.
Imagine it has four or five
prepositional phrases, and there are
even more possibilities to figure out.
It's also hard to do precise deep
semantic analysis, so here's example in
the sentence.
John owns a restaurant.
How do we define owns exactly the word
own is something that we understand, but
it's very hard to precisely describe
the meaning of own for computers.
So as a result, we have robust and
general natural language processing
techniques that can process a lot of
text data.
In a shallow way, meaning we only do
superficial analysis.
For example, parts of speech tagging or
partial parsing or recognizing
sentiment, and those are not deep
understanding 'cause we're not really
understanding the exact meaning of a
sentence.
On the other hand, the deeper
understanding techniques tend not to
scale up well, meaning that they would
fail on some unrestricted text.
And, if you don't restrict the text
domain or the use of words, then these
techniques tend not to work well.
They may work well based on machine
learning techniques on the data that
are similar to the training data that
the program has been trained on, but
generally wouldn't work well.
The data that are very different from
the training data, so this pretty much
summarizes the state of the art of
natural language processing.
Of course, within such a short amount
of time, we can't really give you a
complete view of NLP, which is big
field an either expect to see multiple
courses on natural language processing.
topic itself, but because of its
relevance to the topic we talk about,
it's useful for you to know the background.
In case you haven't been exposed to
that.
So what does that mean for text
retrieval?
In text retrieval, we're dealing with
all kinds of text.
It's very hard to restrict the text to a
certain domain.
And we also often dealing with a lot of
text data.
So that means the NLP techniques must be
general, robust, and efficient, and that
just implies today we can only use
fairly shallow and NLP techniques for
text retrieval.
In fact, most search engines today use
something called a bag of words
representation.
Now, this is probably the simplest
representation you can possibly think
of.
That is to turn text data into
simply a bag of words, meaning we will
keep individual words, but will ignore
all the orders of words.
And we'll keep duplicated occurrences
of words.
So this is called a bag of words
representation.
When you represent the text in this
way, you ignore a lot of other
information and that just makes it
harder to understand the exact meaning
of a sentence, because we've lost the
order.
But yet this representation tends to
actually work pretty well for most
search tasks, and this is partly because
the search task is not all that
difficult.
If you see matching of some of the
query words in a text document, chances
are that that document is about the topic,
although there are exceptions.
So in comparison, some other tasks, for
example machine translation, would
require you to understand the language
accurately, otherwise the translation
would be wrong.
So in comparison, search task is all
relatively easy.
Such a representation
is often sufficient, and that's also
the representation that the major
search engines today, like a Google or
Bing or using.
Of course I put in parentheses is here, but
not all.
Of course there are many queries that
are not answered well by the current
search engines and they do require a
representation that would go beyond the
bag of words representation that would
require more natural language
processing to be done.
There was another reason why we have
not used the sophisticated NLP
techniques in modern search engines,
and that's because some retrieval
techniques actually naturally solve the
problem of NLP.
So one example is word sense
disambiguation.
Think about the world like Java.
It could mean coffee, or could mean
program language.
If you look at the world alone, it
would be ambiguous, but when the user
uses the word in the query, usually
there are other words.
For example, I'm looking for usage of
Java applet.
When I have applet there that implies.
Java Means program language.
And that context can help us naturally
prefer documents where Java is referring
to program language 'cause those
documents would probably match applet
as well if Java
occurs in the document in a way that it means
coffee.
Then you would never match applet or
with very small probability, right?
So this is the case when some retrieval
techniques naturally achieve the goal
of word sense disambiguation.
Another example is.
Some technical code feedback which we
will talk about later in some of the
lectures.
This technical code would allow us to add
additional words to the query and those
additional words could be related to
the query words.
And these words can help matching
documents where the original query
words have not occurred.
So this achieves to some extent.
Semantic matching of terms.
So those techniques also helped us
bypass some of the difficulties in
natural language processing.
However, in the long run we still need
deeper natural language processing
techniques in order to improve the
accuracy of the current search engines,
and it's particularly needed for
complex search tasks.
Or for question answering.
Google has recently launched Knowledge
Graph and this is one step toward that
goal.
'cause knowledge graph would contain
entities and their relations, and this
goes beyond the simple bag of words
representation and such technique
should help us improve the search
engine utility significantly.
Although this is still an open topic for
research and exploration. In summary
in this lecture we talked about what is
an NLP and
We've talked about the state of the art
techniques, what we can do, what we
cannot do, and finally, we also explain
the why bag of words
representation remains the dominant
representation used in modern search
engines, even though deeper NLP would
be needed for future search engines.
If you want to know more, you can take
a look at some additional readings.
I only cited one here and that's a good
starting point.
Thanks.